mayor bajo cerco 1800 policías de la
gendarmería han sido desplegados para
reforzar la seguridad de La Isla desde
hace varias horas las fuerzas del orden
han aumentado los operativos de registro
y control de identidad y es que las
autoridades francesas quieren expulsar a
10.000 personas indocumentadas de mayor
regresandolas en su mayoría al
archipiélago de las comoras ubicados 70
kilómetros
es una operación anti crimen para
recuperar el orden hay barrios en mallot
con bebés y ancianos que están sin agua
ni luz y eso no se puede permitir en
Francia luego hay personas en
situaciones regulares y los deportaremos
como debe ser clásico desde el
archipiélago de las comodoras han
señalado que no tienen intención de
acoger a quienes resulten expulsados en
esta operación pues no tienen los medios
para hacerlo
el departamento francés de mayor es
hasta la fecha el territorio de altamar
más pobre de la Unión Europea el índice
de inseguridad ha alcanzado cifras
récord por lo que hay muchos habitantes
que apoyan esta operación policial
queremos personas que nos protejan no
podemos siquiera salir de nuestras Casas
porque vienen a incendiarlas no es
posible la preocupación también es mayor
por los menos favorecidos las fuerzas
del orden Deben comenzar Este martes con
una operación que tiene por objetivo el
desmantelamiento de varios barrios y
muchos residentes corren el riesgo de
terminar en las calles la asociación
derecho a la vivienda denuncia una
política de alojamiento excesivamente
brutal y pide el cese de esta operación